dregg's coming back now and he's gonna
show you how we use GCP and firebase
together to really modernize corporate
IT ops Greg thanks Bryan Bryan told you
we're gonna take an example of an
existing on-premise and we're gonna
modernize it with Google cloud now in
this case the app that Chris and I are
going to work with is an old asp.net
application well that's not an asp.net
application
that's an asp.net application this is an
application used by an insurance company
so the adjusters go out in the field
they take the digital camera they take
pictures of the accidents they put it in
their SD cards and then they upload the
images into the application it's also
got an API on it so that you can manage
all the images that are associated with
a given claim now we're gonna start
bringing this application out of the 90s
and into the modern era we're gonna
start by giving our agents a good mobile
application so they don't have to lug a
laptop around firebase makes that super
easy you can build a mobile application
without having to be a back-end expert
in this case what Chris is showing you
is the line of code that integrates
firebase with cloud storage so this line
of code allows the camera to take a
picture that picture then automatically
gets uploaded into a Google cloud
storage bucket so to show this is gonna
happen chris is gonna take a quick photo
with the phone yep
all right everyone say cheese
I love having audiences do that okay so
that photo now is being uploaded and
it's being stored into a Google cloud
storage bucket now to show that it
really isn't a GCS bucket we're gonna
switch over we're gonna list the
contents of this bucket now the Windows
users among you are gonna notice that
he's using PowerShell that's because
he's using cloud tools for PowerShell
what gives Windows developers a
first-class experience using Google
cloud platform with the services that
they love and sure enough there's the
picture it was just uploaded today so
now we've got a claim picture in GCS how
do we get it to this old legacy
application Appaji and cloud functions
make that simple the good news is our
legacy app has an API as I mentioned the
bad news is the app was written over a
decade ago so it's a soap API so it's
not really very friendly to a modern
restful developer like Chris Apogee
however is an enterprise API management
platform and we're going to start by
using it to create a proxy to convert
this legacy soap XML into modern JSON so
here's the apogee console we've
connected it
to the the wisdom of the service I can't
believe I'm saying that in 2017
and on the left side you see the soap
XML and on the right side Appaji has
automatically created a much friendlier
easier for the developer to use JSON
version of it now Appaji has a lot of
other capabilities so in addition to
doing that Chris has applied a quota so
that we don't flood this poor service
with millions of mobile agents all
trying to upload photos at the same time
it automatically provides throttling
we've also put authentication in so that
only our agents and only those mobile
applications can upload the data now
fire Appaji 'he's got tons more
capabilities i am only scratching the
surface but for our purposes that's good
enough for this application so we got
images in a GCS bucket we got our
application that's now got a nice modern
api on it how do we connect the two well
I could deploy a VM but that's overkill
right all I want to do is copy a little
file from GCS to an API why should I
pick an operating system and have to
patch the OS and deploy a big heavy VM
image cloud functions allows me to just
write a snippet of JavaScript this
javascript is listening to that GCS
bucket so anytime a file gets added this
snippet gets invoked and if he goes down
you'll see he's using the post method
that nice restful interface onto our web
service so now when chris takes a
picture we should see the picture go all
the way through now I don't have a car
crash on stage Chris I think you've got
those some sort of a next best thing for
us actually what I'm prepared to do Greg
is I've got some scale model vehicle
replicas here that I'm going to use to
simulate a high speed collision scenario
this is scaled down and it exactly right
you ready yeah go for it
yeah please tell me you didn't misplace
the phone so he's gonna take the picture
of oh the humanity
and it gets uploaded and now he's gonna
switch back to our application our
corporate app he's can hit f5 because
it's the 90s we have to refresh and
there we go there's our application we
started with the legacy on-prem app we
used firebase to build a mobile
application that didn't even require a
back-end expert we wrap the old soap API
and modern JSON and cloud functions was
this wonderful glue layer to connect
everything together but one more thing
this application started as an on-prem
application and we've wrapped it with
all this amazing cloud stuff but it's
still sitting on Prem let's fix that bug
to with just a couple clicks Chris will
start the cloud the migration wizard and
in about 45 minutes we will live migrate
this running service into Google cloud
platform where it runs on Google's
amazing infrastructure network
operations and reliability and now we've
really taken this app and brought it
into the modern era